ドクタ～はじめだ。
やあ、みんな。え～と
みなさんは金庫というものをご存じだろうか
ちょっと持ってきましょう
金庫なんであんまり買う機会はないんですけど
ファイアセーフ・ケースというものでございます。
でもなんかマジですごそうでしょ？
この人がこの金庫のすごさを全て表しています。
ドヤ顔で
これどんな物かと言いますと
まさに金庫です。
セーフケースというわけで
火災は貴重品や大切な書類を奪います
火災にあった場合、貴方の大切な書類は大丈夫ですか？
書類ですね、書類とかを守れる金庫でございます。
うわぁ
鍵がついてる
これが金庫です
重っ！
あー　開いた
うわぁ
中身がこんな感じになっております。
この中に物を入れても
例えばこの家が、もし不意の事故で火事になってしまったと
そうなった時でも この中にある物だけはしっかり
炎から守られるという
火に強い 金庫でございます
金庫って言うのかな
金目の物も入るから金庫っしょ
今回私は思ったのだが
この金庫
これすなわち
のではないかという
今回は内部で
もし内部で火災が発生した時
外部の世界は果たして大丈夫なのかどうかという実験をしてみたいと思います
今回こちらにロケット花火700発準備しました
今回はこの金庫の中でロケット花火700発をぶっ飛ばして
果たして 私の家は無事なのかどうかを
検証してみたいと思います
もしこれでね
内部の火災を守れずに外部を あれだったらもうあれですよ
やっぱ自分は 守れても回りの人を守れなかったら
所詮はそこまでの男ってこ…
ひとまず中にロケット花火700発入れていきましょう
うわ～こわい やばいやばい
これ大変やで
わーわーわー
まじこれヤバイな
爆発物の量だよ
うわぁ
700発連続とか多分
外でもあんまりやっちゃいけないレベルだと思うんすよ
それを家の中でできるなんてなんたることでしょう
うげ～ 大丈夫なんだろうね？
はいというわけで
700発のロケット花火でました
え、大丈夫だと思いたいよ
大丈夫大丈夫 多分大丈夫
で、今回なんですけども
このロケット花火 をさ、
金庫の中でやることなんて無いと思うので
中の映像を撮りたいと思いまして
こちらの何か、無駄に強い小型カメラを準備しました
これをこの中に入れて、何度か花火が金庫の中で炸裂している映像を撮りたいと思ったので
ちょっと、それ用の装置を作りましょう
オッケー
花火が来ても 跳ね返せる様なシールドをはって
中に入れておきたいと思います
多分壊れます
普通の部屋でやると危ないので
安全な場所に行ってやります
では行こう！
はい というわけで実際にやっていこう
いやこれガチでちょっととりたいんだけど
大丈夫？
オッケーオッケーオッケー
こんな感じで行きましょう
果たして 大切な物を守れる人は 周りの人も守れるのでしょうか？
では行こう！
え～ 開けんの～？
待ってここから開けるのは至難の業だよ
開けんの？
開けるの？
開けるの？？？？
開けるしかないよね…
バン!!
からんからぁぁぁン!!!
がちゃ
ぱぁん！！！
ぱんぱぁん　　ぱぁんぱぁんぱんぱん…
ちゃりん
爆発音
？？（煙??こわいよぉ）
（ひぃぃぃ）
（もうこわいよぉ）
（け、煙がすごい…）
爆発音
パン　パン!!
～がらん！！
♪~ED~♪
ずぱぱぱぱぱぱぱぱ
ぱぱぱんぱぱぱぱぱぱぱ
ぱんぱんぱんがらぱんぱんぱあんぱんぱん